every on me girl from Columbia Business
School and I'm here enjoying the snow in
devils and I'd like to just share some
of the observations that came out of a
session we did this morning on leading
under pressure it was it was really
inspiring me Nobel laureates way we got
a number really inspiring young leaders
there and one of the things we spent
some time thinking about was the idea
that leadership is a natural substance
maybe stakeholders think no one to turn
to make as well as soon as our iPhone we
focus too much on the substitutes I
don't have pay enough attention to the
signal is yes and several participants I
really appreciated hearing about the
idea of symbolism as well as substance
making it seem legitimate as an
important component of engaging hearts
and minds and getting people to India
follow you under conditions of high
uncertainty and volatility in your
pocket